tom cruise se donne corps et âme dans le
sixième film de la série mission
impossible
le célèbre acteur incarne à nouveau une
agent secret étonnante
il doit une fois de plus sauvé le monde
en empêchant un groupe de terroristes
baptisé les apôtres de faire exploser du
plutonium en grande quantité toute son
équipe seraient mortes
oui probablement ce sont les risques du
métier
les revirements de situation dans ce
film d'espionnage et certains dilemmes
cornéliens sont parfois difficile à
suivre
mais ce n'est pas si important parce
qu'après tout les nombreux saints
d'action accompagné d'une g sonore de
circonstance nous font presque oublier
tout le reste critique s'échangent
en effet ce film est une avalanche de
cascades tourné en grande partie à paris
la scène de la poursuite à moto dans les
rues de la ville est à couper le souffle
et un klose qui signe lui même ses
cascades fait preuve d'audace mais
qu'est ce que tu attends je saute du
haut d'un immeuble dont ce n'est pas
surprenant qu'il se soit blessé pendant
le tournage
il s'est écoulé 22 heures depuis le
premier mission impossible mettant en
vedette tom cruise l'acteur qui vient de
célébrer ses cinquante six ans a bien
sûr quelques raids en plus mais il est
dans une forme à faire des jaloux il
court à toute vitesse ils sautent comme
si c'était la fin du monde
il grimpe à bord d'un hélicoptère au
risque de sa vie les amateurs de films
d'action en auront pour leur argent
même si je ne suis pas un amateur du
genre cette mégaproduction de près de
150 millions de dollars mon ami plein
les yeux
à tel point que c'est à se demander s'il
s'agit là d'un film d'action de n'était
ici l'ouest depuis mai raj qu'un dame en
rien